we already know a little bit about
random variables what we're going to see
in this video is that they're random
variables come in two varieties you have
discrete random variables and you have
continuous random variables continuous
and discrete random variables these are
essentially random variables that can
take on distinct or separate values and
we'll give examples of that in a second
so that comes straight from the the
meaning of the word discrete in the
English language distinct distinct or
separate separate values while
continuous and I guess they're just
another definition for the word de
screening of language should be polite
or not obnoxious or kind of subtle that
is not what we're talking about rent we
are not talking about random variables
that are polite we're talking about ones
that are just that ones that can take on
distinct values and continuous random
variables they can take on any value in
a range and that range could even be
infinite so any any value in an interval
in an interval in an interval so with
those two definitions out of the way
let's look at some actual random
variable definitions and I want to think
together about whether you would
classify them as discrete or continuous
random variables so let's say that I
have a random variable capital X and it
is equal to it is equal to well this is
one that we covered in the last video
it's one if if my fair coin is heads
it's zero if my fair coin is tails so is
this a discrete or a continuous random
variable well this Vallot this random
variable right over here can take on
distinct values it can take on either a
1 or it could take on a 0 another way to
think about is you can count the number
of different values it can take on this
is the first value it can take on this
is the second value that it can take on
so this is clearly this is clearly a
discrete this is a discrete random
variable discrete random
let's think about another one let's
define random variable Y as equal to the
mass the mass of a random random animal
animal selected at the selected at the
New Orleans zoo New Orleans zoo where I
grew up the ottoman zoo at the New
Orleans at the New Orleans zoo the
Audubon zoo why is the mass of a random
animal selected at the New Orleans zoo
is this a discrete random variable or a
continuous random variable well the
exact mass the end and I should probably
put that qualifier here I'll even add it
here just to make it really really clear
the exact mass of a random animal or a
random object in our universe it can
take on any of a whole set of values I
mean who knows exactly the exact number
of electrons that are a part of that
object right at that moment who knows
the neutrons the protons the exact
number of molecules in that in that
object or part of that animal exactly
that moment so that mass for example at
the zoo it might take on a value
anywhere between well maybe close to
zero
close to zero there's no animal that has
zero mass but it could be close to zero
if we're thinking about an ant or we're
thinking about a dust mite or maybe even
a maybe if you consider even a bacterium
an animal
I believe bacterium is a singular of
bacteria and it could go all the way
maybe the most massive animal in the zoo
is the elephant of some kind and I don't
know what it would be in kilograms but
it would be fairly large so maybe you
can get up all the way to 3,000
kilograms or probably larger say 5,000
5,000 5,000 kilograms I don't know what
the mass of a very heavy elephant or a
very massive elephant I should say
actually is it maybe something fun for
you to look at but any animal could have
a mass anywhere in between here there it
does not take on discrete values you
could have a animal that is exactly that
is exactly
123 point seven five nine two one
kilograms and even there that's actually
might not be the exact mass you might
have to get even more precise one zero
seven three two and I get I think you
get the picture there it could there's a
even though this is the way I've defined
now a finite interval you can take on
any value in between here there are not
discrete values so this one is clearly
this is one here is continually a
continuous random variable continuous
continuous random variable let's think
about another one let's think about
let's say that random variable Y instead
of it being this let's say it's the year
the year that a random student in the
class was born random student in a class
was born
is this a discrete or a continuous
random variable well that year you
literally can define it as a specific
discrete year it could be it could be
1992 or it could be 1985 or it could be
2000 and 2001 there are discrete values
that this random variable can actually
can actually take on it won't be able to
take on any value between say 2000 and
2001 it'll either be 2000 or it'll be
2001 or 2002 once again you can count
the values it can take on most of the
times that you're dealing with is in the
case right here a discrete a discrete
random variable and let me make it clear
this one over here is also a discrete
random variable most of the time that
you're dealing with the discrete random
variable you are probably going to be
dealing with a finite number of values
but it does not have to be a finite
number of values you can actually have
an infinite potential number a potential
number of values that it could take on
as long as the values are countable as
long as you can literally say okay this
is the first value can take on the
second the third and you might be
counting forever but as long as you can
literally
it could be even an infinite list but if
you could list the values that it could
take on then you're dealing with the
discrete random variable notice in this
scenario with the zoo you could not list
all of the possible masses you could not
even count them you could you know you
might attempt to and it's it's a fun
exercise to try at least once to try to
list all of the values this might take
on you might say okay maybe we can you
could take on 0.01 and maybe 0.02 but
wait you just skipped an infinite number
of values that it could take on because
it could have taken on zero point zero 1
1 zero point zero one two and even
between those there's an infinite number
of values you could take on there's no
way for you to count the number of
values that a continuous random variable
can take on there's no way for you to
list them with a discrete random
variable you can count the values you
can list the values let's do another
example let's let random variable Z
Capital Z be the number of ants number
of ants born tomorrow born tomorrow in
the universe in the universe now you're
probably arguing that there aren't ants
on other planets or maybe they're ant
light creatures but they're they're not
going to be ants as we define them but
how do we know so a number of ants born
in the universe maybe some ants have
figured out interstellar travel of some
kind so the number of ants born tomorrow
in the universe that's my random
variable Z is this a discrete random
variable or a continuous random variable
well once again we can count the number
of values this could take on this could
be 1 it could be 2 it could be 3 it
could be 4 it could be 5 quadrillion
ants it could be 5 quadrillion in 1 we
can actually count the values those
values are discrete so once again this
right over here is a discrete this right
over here is a discrete random variable
this is fun so let's keep doing more of
these let's say that I have random
variable well let's say I random
variable X so we're not we're not using
this definition anymore now I'm going to
define random variable X to be the
winning time let me write it this way
the exact winning time exact
time winning time for the men's men's
100-meter 100-meter dash at the 2016
Olympics 2016 Olympics so the exact time
that it took for the winner who's
probably going to be Hussain Bolt but it
might not be actually he's aging a
little bit but whatever the exact
winning time for the men's 100-meter
dash of the 2016 Olympics and not the
one that you necessarily see on the
clock the exact the precise time that
you would see at the men's 100-meter
dash is this a discrete or continuous
random variable
well the way I've defined it and this
one's a little bit tricky because you
might say it's countable you might say
well it could either be it could be 956
nine point five six seconds or nine
point five seven seconds or nine point
five eight seconds and you might be
tempted to believe that because when you
watch the hundred meter dash at the
Olympics they measure it to the nearest
hundredths they round to the nearest
hundredths that's how precise their
timing is but I'm talking about the
exact the exact winning time the exact
number of seconds it takes for that
person to from the starting gun to cross
the finish line and there it can take on
any value it can take on any value
between well I guess they're limited by
the speed of light but it could take on
any value you could imagine and you know
it might be anywhere between five
seconds five seconds and maybe 12 12
seconds it could be anywhere in between
there it might not be nine point five
seven that might be what the clock says
but in reality the exact winning time
could be nine point five seven one or it
could be nine point five seven two three
five nine I think you see what I'm
saying the exact precise time could be
any value in an interval so this right
over here is a continuous continuous
random variable now what would be the
case instead of saying the exact winning
time if instead I defined X to be the
winning time of the men's 100-meter dash
at the 2016 Olympics rounded rounded to
the nearest the nearest hundred
nearest hundredths hundredths is this a
discrete or a continuous random variable
so let me delete this I've changed the
random variable now is this going to be
a discrete or continuous random variable
well now we can actually count the
actual values that this random variable
can take on it might be nine point five
six
it could be nine point five seven it
could be nine point five eight we can
actually list them so in this case when
we rounded to the nearest hundredths we
can actually list the values we are now
just dealing with a discrete discrete
random variable discrete random variable
anyway I'll let you go there hopefully
this gives you a sense of the
distinction between discrete and
continuous random variables